chapter of fasting. We
discussed a lot of what had a
lot of the things with regards
to fasting. A lot of the
rulings, a lot of the
narrations, etcetera. However,
we did not conclude all of what
Ibn nu Kaim Rahim spoke about
with regards to fasting. And
there is some follow up as well
that is involved. And that is
that what days are preferable
for a person to fast, what days
are impermissible outside of
the month of Ramadan? This is
something important for us to
continue even though the month
of Ramadan for this year is now
behind us.
[Silence]
you know, kiss my wife or
fondle my wife while I'm while
I am fasting. The prophet
allowed him to do so. And
another came to him and asked
him the same question. And he
prohibited him. He said, no,
that's not permissible. And so,
the narrator concludes that the
person that asked him and he
allowed him was an elder,
elderly gentleman and the
person that he prohibited, the
same thing, was a young man.
This narration is collected by
Abu Daud Rahima Allah in the
book of fasting of his and it
is an inauthentic narration. It
is
narrated with an acceptable
chain of transmission from the
prophet yet we can still
understand the spirit of this
narration even though it is
inauthentic, there are other
verses in the Quran narrations
that do articulate a similar
meaning. What is the reason?
Well, it's you know, the the
spirit of the narration is that
a person who is older, if he
were to kiss his wife or if he
were to touch his wife, you
know, a hug or something while
they are fasting, he will be
able to control himself and not
let it go beyond that because
what's prohibited is
intercourse. While a person is
fasting. And so, the older
person, a person who is an old
man, usually is more capable of
containing himself and
containing his urges. Whereas a
young man maybe newly wed,
maybe has a very strong perhaps
insatiable desire and if this
person were to kind of open
that can of worms, they would
not be able to unring that bell
per se. That's a kiss would
lead to you know, that which
would be a major sin in Islam
which is intercourse during the
day of Ramadan. For the, for
one who is fasting and so,
this spirit is correct and that
is that if a person is unable
to contain himself and this
thing will directly lead them
to that which is haram or most
likely lead them to that which
is haram then it becomes haram
in itself. Whether the person
is old or young. There's not
really a a set difference.
Human beings, they vary.
They're hormone, their hormones
vary their the their, you know,
their libido or their drive
varies and so, some are more
able to discipline themselves
and contain themselves while
others are not And so, if a
person understands from himself
that he is unable to control
himself, then, that would
become impermissible if it
certainly or most certainly
will lead to that which is
haram and this goes with
everything. It's not just in
fasting. This is a general
rule. Allah Allah said to Adam
and
do not come near this tree.
What is prohibited is eating
from the tree. But he
prohibited them from coming
near the tree because coming
near it will directly result in
them falling into that which is
haram. So this narration is
inauthentic. However what we
can take away from this and
what the scholars have driven
home in the spirit of such
narrations is that if a person
is unable to contain himself,
then this may become haram
whereas a person who is able to
control himself, then there is,
in essence, nothing wrong and
it does not interfere with a
person's fast to kiss or or do
any of the things that a
husband and wife would usually
do as long as there is no
intercourse involved
And Quran
Al
[Silence]
specific way, eating or
drinking, anything
intentionally or that which
takes the place of eating or
drinking or that which goes the
path of food and drink. This
will break a person's fast and
we discuss this in detail in
our previous discussions. We're
just going over it because
Allah mentions it here as part
of the book. Another thing that
he mentions is that Al Hijama,
cupping will break a person
fast, cupping. What is cupping?
Cupping is a prophetic medicine
where a person will have blood
drawn. So, the area that they
are cupping will, you know,
there will be suction and then,
a razor will be used to let the
blood and then more suction and
it will it's called blood
letting or cupping. And this is
something that the scholars of
Hadith on whether or not it
breaks a person's fast. There
are few narrations in this
regard Number one, there's a
narration that Al Imam Al
Bukhari Rahima Allah mentions
in his in his authentic
compilation. But he mentions it
without a chain of narration.
Which means that it's not part
of Sahih Al Bukhari. You know,
Sahih Al Bukhari, what is Sahih
Al Bukhari or the narrations
that he mentions with his
chains of narration, right?
There are chains of there are
other narrations that he'll
just mention in passing but he
won't mention a chain of
narration because they don't
meet his criteria. One of these
narrations is that the prophet
did cupping while he was
fasting. That's how the
narration goes. He did cupping,
blood letting while he was
fasting. In other narrations,
it was that he did this cupping
while he was in Ihram. So, the
narrators differ on what the
narration actually is.
Difference of opinion.
Al Imam Ahmed Rahima Allah. his
opinion with regards to this
narration is that blood letting
will break a person's fast.
There's another narration in a
that states that the prophet
said
that the person who does the
cupping and the person who
receives the cupping, both of
them have in their fast. This
narration is also a point of
discussion amongst the scholars
of Hadith and its meaning is
also a differed upon. The
opinion that is most sound that
the majority of the scholars
hold is that blood letting will
not break a person's fast in
and of itself. Meaning, if a
person, you know, why is this
important. It's important
because a lot of things are
derived and based on this kind
of narration. is the prophet
saying that blood letting,
cupping in and of itself breaks
a person's fast even if it's
just a few drops, even if it's
just a little bit. it's known
that for instance, if you were
to eat a big meal eat a big
meal and then you go to do this
cupping. You go to do this
blood letting or even if you go
to draw blood, you will not be
able to get very much blood at
all because most of the blood
rushes to the stomach to help
with the digestive process. So,
is there a difference? If a lot
of blood comes out or even if
just a little bit or the mere
action of blood letting will
break a persons fast The
opinion that the majority of
the scholars hold is that blood
letting will not break a
person's fast. In and of
itself. Meaning that it, the
action itself, if you have
blood drawn, if you bleed, if
you have a tooth pulled, then
you start to bleed, or if a, if
you get a cut and you bleed a
lot, does this break your fast?
The answer is no. This will not
break a person's fast in and of
itself. For person goes to
donate blood. Will that break
their fast? No. In and of
itself, it will not. However,
if a person
bleeds out or if a person, you
know, has some kind of accident
or if a person has blood drawn
and they become dizzy and they
become weary and they and a
person has to break their fast
to eat, to regenerate their
body. So, the the blood letting
itself does not break a
person's fast. Whereas,
a person may need to break his
fast for some other reason but
the blood itself coming out of
the body will not break a
person's fast in the opinion of
the majority of the scholars.
He says in the Quran, indicates
that intercourse will break a
person's fast and it is not
known that any scholar has ever
differed on this issue. No
scholar in the history of Islam
who was notable. Has been known
to say that intercourse will
not break a person's fast. All
of the scholars agree that
intercourse will break a
person's fast. He says and it's
not authentic what has been
narrated with regards to all
the narrations regarding
which is coal in the eye that
this will break a person's
fast. There are some narrations
that putting something in the
eye ran for a woman makeup
or for a man, you know, coil or
eye drops or something of that
sort, that this will break a
person's fast. Why? Because
sometimes a person may use
something in his eye and
kind of have a taste of it
in the back of his throat. Feel
some of that eye drop had
reached to the back of his
throat. Will this break a
person's fast? No. There's no
narration that is authentic
regarding anything the
regarding the eye being a path
that will break a person's
fast. What do we mean by path
fast? Well, we said what leads
into the into the stomach,
right? So, a path that leads
into the stomach is the mouth,
a path that leads into the
stomach is the nose, right? But
the eye is not a path that
leads to the stomach. I mean,
there maybe some residual thing
that may you know, find its way
into a person's throat but it's
not an a normal to the stomach.
So, it is not something that is
considered to break a person's
fast.
Ibn Then goes on to mention
some of the times when it is
most preferable for a person to
fast. And in San you know
Ramadan Adel Suyam Islam
[Silence]
you know, optional fasting What
is the best time to fast? A
person can essentially fast any
day of the year. There are
certain days when it is
prohibited to fast. We will get
into those days inshallah. But
for the most part, aside from
these five or six days which is
prohibited for a person to
fast. An optional fast. And a
person can fast any day. You
can fast Monday. You can fast
Tuesday, Wednesday, Thursday.
You can fast. However, what is
preferable? If I wanted to
choose a day or if I wanted to
choose a month or if I wanted
to choose a series of days
then, which of these times is
preferable for me to fast? He
mentions fasting the month or
the 10 days of the
The companions differed. Some
of them said, he fasted the
first 10 days of the meaning,
day one through day nine
including the day of Arafah.
It's referred to as the ten of
the just in a general
generalized fashion. Otherwise,
it's actually nine days because
you're not going to fast the
day of Eid which is the tenth
day, right? So, some of the
companions said, yes, he
fasted. These 10 days of the
hijjah. While other compan
said, no, he did not fast,
right? This is a difference of
opinion amongst the companions
Some of them said he fasted,
others said, no, he did not
fast. This is something that is
rare. It's not common in
narrations that the companions
the
[Silence]
doesn't happen often This is
very rare actually. However, it
does come up. where a companion
will say the prophet did not do
this. And another companion
will say, he did do this. If we
are at that crossroads, and we
are unable to harmonize the two
statements. We're not a to
harmonize those two statements.
They are mutually exclusive.
They are opposing statements.
One says, he did it, the other
says he didn't. What do we do
in this case? So, we have kind
of a checklist. Number one, we
look at the chains of
narration. We see, are the
chains of narration authentic?
Are they correct? Now, I'm I'm
obviously talking to you about
what the scholars do. When I
say we, I mean, the the the
that the scholars go through We
look at the chain of narration.
We make sure that both are
authentic narrations because if
one of them is weak and the
other is authentic, we take the
authentic, right? So, if both
narrations are authentic, Then,
we go to the second level and
that is trying to harmonize the
two statements. I need to try
to make peace, make harmonize
where both statements are used.
If this is not possible, then,
we have a third and final stage
where I have to choose one. One
can be, has to be correct and
the other has to be correct.
It's not possible for yes and
no to be both correct at the
same time, right? In in the
exact same way. So, Ibn Kayim,
he gives us a very valuable
principle and that principle
states that in this rare
occasion if one says this did
not happen and the other says,
this did happen then, we take
the one who we give precedence
to, the one who affirms that
action. The one who says, I saw
him do this, that narration,
that statement takes precedence
over, he never did this Because
which one is more general. He
never did this. That's a much
more broad statement, correct?
As opposed to someone saying, I
saw him do this. That's much
more specific and in Islamic
logic, Islamic logicians, Yani,
Ali Osul, they mentioned that.
That which is specific, takes
precedence over that which is
general. Let's give an example
of this. So, There's a
narration
in which
He says, I saw the prophet
while we were travelling and we
came over this area and it was
kind of an inhospitable area.
It was where the it was the the
mezbola is the place where you
know, the the community, the
the the village, they all throw
their garbage. It's the
the village dump if you will.
And the prophet needed to
relieve himself. However, if he
were to sit to relieve himself
it was more likely that he
would soil his clothing, soil
himself, and so says, I saw
him, that he stood covering his
private parts and and relieved
himself. Meaning, you're a
nation, right? So, Hadefa said,
I saw this. We were traveling.
We were going to war and a
journey and I saw him do this.
I, Ishel on the other hand, she
said, the prophet never himself
standing up. It never happened
Whoever tells you that he did
is wrong. So, now we have
Hadefa saying, I saw this
happen and Aisha saying, he
never did this. We go through
our checklist, right? Number
one, we have to check on the
chain of narration. Both of
them are authentic. We have
number two, we have to
harmonize, right? Well, Isha,
the way that she said it it's
not possible to harmonize this
narrations because Aisha said,
whoever tells you he did is
wrong.
Heather. He said, whoever tells
you this, doesn't know what
he's talking about. He's wrong.
So, it's not possible to
harmonize between the statement
of and the statement of Aisha.
But the question here has to
come up. Was Aisha with the
prophet every single time he
went everywhere.
It's not possible. She she was
not, right? Yeah. So, is it
possible that I, Isha, spoke
about what she always saw every
time she witnessed the prophet
relieving himself or speaking
about it or teaching it. It was
always sitting down. Is it not
possible that she spoke about
what she saw and it was so
overwhelmingly so to the point
where said, he never did this
and if anyone tells you that he
did otherwise, they are wrong.
We understand from this that in
normal circumstances, he would
never urinate standing. If he
had an option, that would not
be his choice.
However, Hudaifa tells us of
what he saw. And was clearly
not there in that incident.
Therefore tells us here
He says, the one who affirms
the action we give precedence
to that testimony over a person
who who completely negates its
existence because negation is
more general than affirmation.
Affirmation is more specific.
So, we conclude from these two
narrations of
that the of the prophet is that
he would under normal
circumstances, hardly ever, if
ever, relieve himself standing.
He would always sit. However,
under pressing circumstances,
he may veer from that but that
is definitely the exception and
not and not the norm. Do we
derive from this that it is
impermissible for a person to
relieve himself standing even
if they can sit? No. Person can
relieve himself in any way that
he chooses as long as he does
not soil himself or soil the
area, etcetera However, there
is a difference between that
which is permissible and that
which is the and we spoke about
this in detail previously.
Allah
was sown.
[Silence]
First month which is the month
of Muharam. The tenth day is
referred to as meaning the day
of the tenth. This tenth day is
a day of fasting for the
Muslims. It had a history,
Ashurah. Ashura was fasted by
the Muslims before fasting the
month of Ramadan became
obligatory. fasting the month
of Ramadan became obligatory in
the second year after Hijra.
the first year when the prophet
first arrived to Medina
saw that the Jews of Medina
would fast the day of Ashura,
the tenth day of the first
month, the month of Muharam.
And so he asked them why do you
guys fast this day? And they
informed him that this is the
day that marks the day when
Allah parted the sea, the Red
Sea, and delivered Musa and his
people, Beni Israel from the
clutches and the bondage of, of
Firaun, and destroyed. It was
on that day, the tenth day of
the month of Muharam and so it
is a grand day and so we, it is
a day of majesty, so we fasted
Out of thankfulness to Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala for that
deliverance. The prophet said,
we are closer to Musa than you
are. We are closer to Musa. Ila
Musa. We are closer to Musa
than you. Meaning, in our
religion, in our following, we
are more similar to Musa than
those who after and lost his
tradition, his legacy and so
the prophet fasted the day of
Ashurah and he also commanded
the Muslims to fast Ashura.
Fasting Ashura at the beginning
was obligatory. It was
obligatory Ramadan. It was
and we discussed this
previously. Then, later on,
when Ramadan was made
obligatory, fasting the month
of Ramadan was made obligatory
with its conditions and its
regulations, Fasting the day of
Ashura later was made into
something which is preferable
for a person to do. It is
preferable to fast the day of
Ashura. It's not obligatory.
The prophet
was asked about the day of
Ashura. He said, fasting the
day of Ashura, its reward is
that a year passed of sins will
be forgiven. A years past of
sins will be forgiven. Meaning,
minor sins. Major sins. They
have other rulings. Major sins,
a person has to repent for
major sins, minor sins,
according to the opinion of the
majority of the scholars. Now,
Fasting the day of Ashura Why
was it obligatory and then
later something that is
preferable and then later, it
had another change which is
just before the prophet died.
In the last year of his life,
he was reminded that the Jews
fast Ashura as well along with
the Muslims. They all fast
together. And so, the prophet
said as is indicated by even
Abbas that if I live till next
year in I will fast a day along
with it. Meaning a day before
it or a day after it. However,
he did not live till the next
year. So, we kind of have three
stages here for the day of
Ashura. and unfortunately, we
have run out of time inshallah
next week. We'll continue our
class and we will discuss this.
A person may say, I need, we're
talking about fasting, fasting
is finished. Let this is not
just about fasting Ramadan.
We're still in the chapter of
fasting and fasting is a pillar
of Islam and it has rulings for
Ramadan and outside of Ramadan.
Muhammad Ali, he was